hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am finishing out a mob month
March with Scarface I watched the first
two hours 31 minutes and 28 seconds of
this film already and I am about to do a
live reaction the first on cameras never
seen of the end of Scarface I don't
really know what I'm in for
but Doug said that I should probably
react to it live on camera I just want
to kind of dive in and start talking
about already but we have to do the
intro of the show so we'll do that who's
gonna put some some flour on my nose
looks like Tamra this is cotton to fill
up your Terry's never seen looks need to
stop what just happened is that Tony
killed his partner and best friends and
younger sister's husband Manny now is
back at his place man he's also hitting
the head of his security so that's cool
people are invading that's fun okay ah
let's get into it
[Music]
you
I've never done a reaction like this
last but I guess maybe should try it
down so we don't get copyright stricken
oh I have seen that parody parody eat
before what were they actually sniffing
for this movie
oh no oh there's just a bunch of people
coming to get him
Oh classic deal rope around my neck
classic look at the cameras look at the
cameras that you bought for the
situation stop snorting like that that's
too much flour it's a hell of a drop
Oh Gina Oh Oh Gina Oh God
way more drama with Gina and Tony happen
in this movie that I ever thought so
weird i close-ups it's all about Gina I
thought it was all gonna be about money
oh she shot I'd like you get him girl Oh
Gina last words from the person that you
love most in this world word come on
Tony
not like I deal that's a large guy you
want to play rough
say hello to my little friend reloading
is always so tense
what flipping shot
Wow
wait what that was michelle pfeiffer 2
hours and 45 minutes
another long-ass movie that I totally
enjoyed this is what I want to see in a
long movie like a story that keeps going
and progressing and you get to see some
action in it things happen yeah sure
it's not as like pretty as The Godfather
and does it feel like as much of a
masterpiece is the Godfather note but it
kept my attention for almost 3 hours so
it has that going for it
and I'm really rooted for Tony all the
way all the way through doing just
terrible things he would redeem himself
he's selling all these drugs he's
killing people and he's ruining lives
and he's ruining his own life and then
you know he's supposed to kill this guy
he doesn't want to kill his wife and
kids and then you like I am back on your
side I'm back on your side Tony this is
based on true events I know this isn't
like 100% based on a true story but I
don't know to what extent it is based on
I know it's based on terms like events
in history like time and place sort of
deals a key comes over from Cuba and the
80s he gets his green card from killing
someone then he rises the ranks with
this drug war invite the killing people
I was very shocked though at the
severity of some of these scenes that
Shane saw scene is I don't know if I've
ever spoken about this on the internet
but chainsaws are the one things that
scare me in movies I don't like
chainsaws simple girl I like cats
don't let chainsaw like when I go to a
haunted house nothing in a haunted house
ever scares me he spooks me fight quite
fun it's fun time fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun chainsaw get me so much
though anytime and Leatherface comes out
at haunted house I'm like I'm done
nope No thank you I've no doubt now that
James I've seen Wow and it was near the
beginning it was in the first like 40
minutes of the film whoa whoa
I love the reveal of Elvira's character
Elmyra Elmyra I'm gonna call her Elvira
Michelle Pfeiffer who knew literally
everyone they have this really romantic
music playing like the music that you
see when you see the love of your life
for the first time and that's what they
were trying to convey for sure but she
comes down this like scantily clad
outfit like this and not much else and
going down like drug lords see through
clear elevator and she comes down he's
looking at this other man's woman like
with his tongue out like a Jim Carrey
the masking and it's so funny the
opposites of that scene but they're
showing you and what you're hearing is
amazing is she just so immersed in his
life that she feels like she can't get
out of it does she like the life because
she seems miserable does she like any of
these men she like Tony does she like
Frank I don't get her character at all I
like her character but I do not
understand the complexities of Elvira
the blonde
yeah what's coming to you the world
should go and everything in it good
lines I really just love that it's him
rising the ranks and getting to exactly
where he wants to be him just being
miserable in that because it's a
terrible soul sucking like I'm sure it
felt a lot more good fellow than
Godfather and I know that none of these
movies are really comparable though they
do all have similar similar people in
them but that's the only thing I think
Al Pacino was so much more interesting
and engaging and spicy in this one then
he was in khawater he was clearly very
good and Godfather but the characters
are of course again so different it's
not no use compare them but this one
death where they kill Omar a little
extravagant don't you think gonna
probably just I don't know stabbed him
he probably didn't have to take him up
in a helicopter
and then choke him a little bit and then
throw him off the helicopter and then
fly around with his body out the
helicopter but you know to each their
own we're not about pink shaming me he
kills Franks to get ahead because Frank
kind of cracks him over he takes out
vibra from Frank and you get the sense
that Elvira is not gonna be happy
anywhere she goes but she's definitely
not she's not happy with with chummy at
all and she's just like girl I want you
to go away find yourself have a little
Eat Pray Love moment you need to
discover yourself for who you are
because you're clearly not happy in this
life I love the scene where he is there
with Manny
and Elvira and they're eating dinner and
he goes off on this drunk rampage about
his wife won't have sex with him and she
can't have a baby because she has her
drugs in her womb and how Manny kind of
screwed him over with the Jewish guy who
got him in trouble and just going off on
this drunken tirade and all of the
people in the restaurant are just was so
fancy observed at this man and like
obviously you would it's so well done it
so well acted he's so good in the scene
and it's obviously well written too but
he is so compelling and believable in
the scene I love watching someone play
drunk really really well most people
have been drunk
it's something that you all know like I
feel like you could spot it if it was
really bad and I've seen some really bad
portrayals oh he just could he was so so
compelling in the scene and then you saw
my reaction to get let's see say hello
to my little friend I was gonna say that
line in the opening and then half the
camera panned down it was just me Ike
but he's napping somewhere so I enjoyed
this more than I enjoyed the Godfather
movies sorry I think I enjoyed
Goodfellas most overall in mob month and
then the Scarface and then Godfather -
and then Godfather one I'm really glad
that I enjoyed two of them a lot and I'm
really glad that I saw Godfather 1 and
Godfather Part 2 and I'm glad that it
kind of changed my mindset on mob movies
it didn't change my mindset on
movies because it's just something that
I don't love somebody the comment says I
go yeah well you'll go binge three hours
game thrones you can't sit down and
watch a movie personal preference
everyone I've also not seen Game of
Thrones I read the books
it's very intense I would give Scarface
9 out of 10 hair flips mostly I'm just
glad that mob month is done every month
some more lighthearted insults all of
next month is going to be collaborations
I'm doing something with Walter with
Malcolm with Doug and with Brad Jones
and I'm very excited you have some other
voices and to take the load up yeah
thank you so much for watching I will
see you all next week
back 100 movies bucket list where are
you
Scarface nice oh shit
The Godfather alright well nice I have a
video where I show how many of those
hundred movie classics I've seen are my
personal shit also check that out ok
back
[Music]
[Applause]
you